the protagonist of the show is Elliot
Alderson a socially awkward and
depressed cyber security engineer from
New York City at first glance his life
is pretty boring his daily routine
consists of going to his workplace a
tech company called all safe avoiding
interaction with people and coming back
home however when it becomes night
Elliot turns into one of the most
interesting people on Earth using his
Advanced cyber security skills he has
become some sort of vigilante no matter
how secure or complex a data encryption
is Elliot will find a way to hack it he
doesn't do it for fun he just wants to
bring Justice to those who need it one
day he enters a coffee shop and sits
next to the rich owner of the place
Rohit at first he has a normal
conversation and talks about the
impressive Wi-Fi installed there however
a few minutes later he changes his
attitude and starts explaining why he's
actually there Elliot reveals that he
hacked into rohit's Network and found
out about his child pornography ring
there were hundreds and thousands of
gut-wrenching videos which Rohit
apparently sells to his customers for
money Elliot also mentions that he has
copied all of the data and files meaning
that Rohit has no means of Escape
hearing all this Rohit becomes worried
but he claims that Elliot cannot inform
the cops as hacking into one's system is
also a crime to his dismay the latter
reveals that he actually contacted the
police right before he entered the shop
via an untraceable number this shows
that Elliot always plans his moves in
advance Rohit who at this point has
become very scared offers him money to
reconsider but Elliot straightforwardly
rejects it claiming that he doesn't care
about money soon the cops arrive and
harass Rohit the following day we see
how a socially awkward Elliot manages
himself in the all safe office he tries
avoiding just about everyone including
his boss Gideon and remains glued to his
computer all the time but there is one
co-worker he loves talking to Angela
it's revealed that the two are childhood
friends and have been very close for
years Elliot has a crush on her but he
can't express his feelings because she
already has a boyfriend after work
Elliot meets his therapist Krista Gordon
we get to know that he meets our at
least three times a week to help cure
his depression as expected Elliot has
hacked into her personal details and
knows everything about her for instance
she is currently dating a middle-aged
guy named Michael Elliot appears to care
for Krista so he tried to hack Michael's
details to know him better but even
after hours of searching on the internet
he couldn't find anything meanwhile as
part of the counseling session Krista
asks him several questions but Elliot
owing to his awkwardness doesn't reply
much as a matter of fact the therapy
isn't helping him at all at home he
usually has bouts of panic attacks which
make him want to commit the unthinkable
and since he has no friends or family
the only way Elliot keeps himself sane
is by ingesting high-strength morphine
here it is revealed that his father died
of leukemia due to radiation exposure
while his abusive mother left him at a
very young age the following day as
Elliott is busy with work at his office
some Executives from a giant tech
company e-corp or aze Elliott calls them
evil Corp arrive Elliot despises the
company Because he believes that they
are greedy money Grabbers who don't care
about their consume rumors at all
however sadly for him evil Corp is
currently funding his company all safe
just then the vice president Tech
officer of evil Corp Tyrell approaches
him and starts chatting over their
shared interest in Linux after work
Elliot returns home and carries out his
routine of ingesting morphine shortly
after he is scrolling through his
therapist Krista's photos when he learns
that her boyfriend Michael has finally
created his social media account this
gives Elliot an idea early the next
morning Elliot pretends to be a stranger
and approaches Michael he then borrows
his phone on the pretext of calling his
mother however he calls his own number
to obtain Michael's phone number after
the work is done he deletes the call
history and Returns the phone on his way
home he suddenly receives a call from
his colleague Angela informing him that
evil corpse server has been DDOS
attacked deep down inside Elliot is
happy and wishes that more damage would
be done but when Angela requests that he
come over to help he immediately obliges
on reaching the office another co-worker
briefs the situation he reveals that the
DDOS attack is the worst they have ever
come across despite trying every single
remedy it won't go away wasting no time
Elliott checks into the system and
learns that the attack is actually
taking place from multiple locations
moreover it is not a DDOS attack but a
root kit that is causing Mayhem now the
only way to get rid of it is by going
offline and terminating all the viruses
Elliot's boss Gideon is skeptical about
the idea as it may result in further
damages to the system but since there
are no other Solutions he agrees to it
the next morning Gideon and Elliot fly
to their Data Center and begin the
recovery at first Elliot redirects
traffic to another server and then
reboots the situation the plan works and
the servers are finally out of danger
later when Elliot is going through the
encrypted files he notices something
strange he finds a text file named F
society that says leave me here Elliott
realizes that the file was meant to be
found by him so he decides against
deleting it instead he hides it inside
evil Corp server so that only he can
access it later in the next scene as
Elliott is returning home via the subway
a strange man named Mr Robot approaches
him he asks Elliot to exit the train and
meet him outside for a chat but only if
he hasn't deleted the text file hearing
this Elliot realizes that Mr Robot is
from F Society the same organization
that attacked evil Corp server hence he
quickly exits the train and follows the
man after a bit of small talk Mr robot
takes Elliot to their workplace on Coney
Island which apparently is a
basement-like room with several
computers unlike other hacking
organizations Mr Robot reveals that here
everyone has to meet physically and do
things together Elliott says screw you
man do you know how many places offer
work from home these days later after
returning home Elliot immediately logs
onto his computer and tries finding out
more about Mr Robot and F Society but it
appears as if they are ghosts there is
literally not a single piece of
information about them the following day
an intrigued Elliot returns to Coney
Island and chats with Mr Robot the
latter Reveals His plan to hack into
giant servers wipe out all of the
world's dead and distribute wealth
evenly among the population in short he
wants to start a financial meltdown and
bring down the disparity between in the
rich and the poor Mr Robot further
reveals that he targeted Eliot because
of his vast cyber hacking skills and
also because he has access to evil Corp
it turns out that evil Corp owns a
whopping 70 of the world's credit
industry Elliot is caught between two
minds as he wants to help those in debt
but at the same time he also believes
that robbing the rich of their
hard-earned money is wrong he mentions
that he will think about it but before
departing Mr Robot assigns him a task
all he has to do is log into evil Corps
server modify the text file from earlier
and enter the IP address of Terry Colby
the CTO of evil Corp that night it
confused Elliot changes the IP address
and puts the records into a file however
he decides against submitting it to the
authorities he hates Terry Colby but he
doesn't want him to go down this way the
next day at work Elliott his colleagues
the FBI and the executives from Evil
Corp are having a meeting about the
Cyber attack Angela is doing her best to
brief the situation but the Arrogant
Colby ignores her and tells her to leave
the meeting this enrages Elliot so he
eventually decides to handle the file
over to the FBI after the incident
several days passed by but the news of
Colby's arrest has not appeared moreover
Mr Robot and his F Society have become
Anonymous prompting Elliot to believe
that he was tricked with nothing else to
do he decides to toy with Trish's
boyfriend Michael he calls him
pretending to be his bank officer and
extracts important details like his
dog's name favorite things and so on
using the information he easily hacks
into Michael's accounts and learns that
he is cheating on tresha with several
women some of whom are underaged that
night Elliot confronts Michael and
reveals that he knows everything he then
blackmails him to come clean with Trisha
or else he will inform the police left
with no choice Michael obliges and thus
their relationship comes to an end a few
weeks later at work the news of evil
Corp CTO Colby's arrest is finally shown
this makes Elliot realize that Mr Robot
and his vision are actually trustworthy
later as he is walking down the busy
street a group of suited men force him
into a car and take him away soon they
reach an office where several men are
waiting for him one of them is evil Corp
VP Tech officer that he met earlier
Tyrell it turns out that he has become
the interim CTO of the company after
Colby's arrest Tyrell gets straight to
the point and offers Elliot the position
of head of cyber security at evil Corp
which would make him a millionaire in
months however after thinking for a
while Elliot politely declines claiming
that he is content with his current work
that night he logs into his computer and
tries hacking tyrell's database
surprisingly the new CEO of Evil Corp
doesn't even use two-step authentication
and Elliot easily gets access to his
emails he Scrolls through it but finds
nothing other than family photos this is
when it strikes Elliot that Tyrell
wanted him to hack his database all
along hence he disconnects his computer
turns off the router and burns the
memory cards to stay Anonymous the next
day at work Gideon summons Elliot to his
office and displays a recent video
released by The Cyber hacking group F
Society in the video an anonymous person
in a mask takes responsibility for the
recent attack on evil Corp and demands
the release of Colby he also threatens
the major credit organizations to
dissolve their assets and to distribute
them evenly among charity organizations
failure to comply will result in these
major organizations getting hacked
seeing the video Elliot once again
assumes that he has been duped later he
returns home to straw only to find
someone in his shower it is Darlene one
of the F Society hackers that he had met
earlier she has come to escort him to
their Hideout for the next mission
Elliott believes that he is going
against the law and fears being caught
but suddenly he realizes that he can
learn more about F society and expose
them once and for all hence he agrees to
go with Darlene on reaching the place
Elliot meets all the team members and
chats with Mr Robot who starts
discussing the next phase of their plan
he orders Elliot to blow up a gas plant
which is next to an off-site evil Corp
data storage facility this will erase
all the data that is transferred to
China hence starting their Uprising
Elliott is intrigued by the plan but
since it involves blowing something up
and killing people he decides to stay
out of it however in the subway he
realizes that he cannot run away from F
society as he has also become one of
them all these incidents have started to
take a toll on Elliot's psyche so he
decides to increase his morphine dosage
he goes to his neighbor's drug dealer
shayla's house only to find a violent
woman abuser and Drug supplier named
Fernando Elliot appears to know
everything about him as he is shayla's
only drug dealer who often visits her he
is the one who supplies the morphine
that Elliot regularly consumes this is
also the reason why Elliott doesn't
expose him to the police if Fernando is
gone his morphine is also gone shortly
after Fernando leaves and Elliot finds
Shayla half unconscious and beaten up in
the bathroom he urges her to inform the
police about the constant abuse she has
been suffering but Shayla refuses saying
Fernando provides her with very good
deals this infuriates Elliot so he
decides to take matters into his own
hands he anonymously leaks Fernando's
details to the police and gets him
arrested even if it means that his
regular morphine Supply is now gone
elsewhere as Angela and her boyfriend
Ollie are walking on the streets a
random guy approaches them and gives him
a CD saying that it's his new mixtape
when they reach home Ollie inserts the
CD into his computer and as soon as he
does so he receives an email from one of
his girlfriends she invites him over to
her place to have fun that night Ollie
being a pervert lies to Angela that he
has a meeting with his friends and
departs surprisingly after he leaves we
can see that a man named Cisco has
hacked into his computer webcam the
following morning Elliott meets up with
Mr Robot and the two sit on a railing to
talk they talk about their past lives
and families but in the midst of it Mr
Robot expresses his displeasure due to
the fact that Elliot abandoned them some
days ago saying this he suddenly Chucks
Elliot from the railing and onto the
rocky Beach Below on the other hand the
interim CEO of Evil Corp Tyrell gives an
inspiring speech to the CEO explaining
why his role should be made permanent
but to his dismay the CEO reveals that
they have found a good candidate whom
they want to try out first hearing this
Tyrell becomes enraged and heads to an
isolated location there he meets a
homeless man Hayes him some cash and
beats him to a pulp to vent his
frustration the men in this show are
more Twisted than the targaryens
meanwhile Elliot wakes up in a hospital
bruised and bandaged he is visited by
his therapist Krista who believes that
he overdosed on morphine and fell from
the railing when Elliot denies this she
asks him to provide her with a blood
sample this is music to Elliot's ears
because the current hospital he is in
has a very weak security system it is
run on Windows 98 and has a puny
antivirus as protection as a result he
easily hacks into it and Alters his
records to make it look like his blood
is free of drugs after getting
discharged Elliot heads to work the next
day where Mr Robot pays him a surprise
visit the two then head to a bar to
discuss but Elliot is still angry about
what happened earlier he tells Mr Robot
that he doesn't want to be a part of his
plan anymore and asks him to be left
alone Mr Robot obliges but before
leaving he reveals that F Society is
going to be defunct as without Elliot
there is no purpose in the plan with the
notorious cyber hacking group out of the
way a big burden is removed from
Elliot's Chest hence he starts becoming
more social and Interactive he asks his
neighbor in close Confidant Shayla out
on a date and also engages in other
normal activities like jogging going out
with friends chatting with people on
social media and so on at night Elliot
Shayla and the other all safe employees
are invited to Gideon's house for dinner
there they reminisce about their work
and the good times they have had
suddenly on the television a News
Channel reports that the notorious
hacker group F Society has struck again
this time they have released huge
amounts of data which reveal that evil
Corp knew about the Washington toxic
waste Scandal which killed several
people due to leukemia including
Elliot's dad and Angela's mom the news
makes Elliot sad but now he has a
purpose to take down the company hence
he quickly leaves the place later when
Angela and Dolly reach home they get
into a minor argument about their recent
relationship status which has been
mostly cold taking this as the perfect
opportunity Ali finally reveals that
someone is hacked into his computer the
hacker Cisco has sent several nude
pictures of Angela along with credit
card details of her father and is
threatening to release them however all
he can stop that from happening if he
infects their workplace all safe
realizing the gravity of the situation
the couple seriously considers doing it
in the final scene Elliot who has
apparently made up his mind arrives at
the F Society base and joins his
teammates this show kicks ass be sure to
catch the following episodes on series
Recaps